Although the trap-and-emulate model
seems like it will solve all problems
and it worked beautifully on the
mainframes, when in the 90s, the need to
reapply virtualization solutions to
the prevalent x86 architecture came up,
it turned out that there were
certain problems with this model.
At the time,
x86 platforms had just the 4 rings.
There wasn't any support for
root or non-root mode.
And so the way to virtualize them would
be to run the hypervisor in ring 0 and
the guest OS in ring 1.
However, it turned out that there
were exactly 17 instructions,
that were privileged in that
hardware would not allow them to be
executed if they're not issued
from the most privileged ring 0.
However, they did not cause a trap.
Issuing them from another protection
level from ring 1 or above
wouldn't pass control to the hypervisor
and instead would just fail silently.
For instance enabling or disabling
interrupts requires manipulating of
a bit in a privileged flags register and
this can be done via
the POPF/PUSHF instructions.
However, when these instructions
are issued from ring1 in
the Pre 2005 architecture,
they just fail and
the instructions pipeline is allowed
to continue to the next instruction.
The problem with the situation
that there is no trap is that
since control isn't
passed to the hypervisor,
the hypervisor has no idea that the OS
wanted to change the interrupt status.
So, the hypervisor will not do anything
to change these settings, will not
emulate the behavior that was required,
that was intended with this instruction.
At the same time because the failure
of the instruction was silent,
the operating system, the guest OS,
doesn't know that anything wrong
happened, so
the OS will continue its execution,
assuming that correctly the interrupts
were enabled or disabled as intend.
So the OS will then go ahead and
perform operations that, for instance,
if interrupted can leave it in
corrupt or in deadlock state.
Which was intended to be avoided by
some manipulation of this flags
register to disable interrupt.
So clearly this is a major problem and
makes this trap-and-emulate approach
not applicable for these architectures.